Tradutor: Debora Branco
Revisor: Vanessa Soneghet
Por que você escolheu
essa roupa para vir aqui hoje?
Que sensações ela te passa?
O que você sente quando a usa?
O que você acha que ela
transmite pras pessoas?
Está confortável, sexy? Moderno, talvez...
Toda roupa que a gente usa
passa alguma mensagem.
E até algumas pessoas aí,
que estão de jeans e camiseta,
todas de preto, podem pensar:
"Não estou passando mensagem alguma".
Mas sem dúvida as nossas escolhas
ou o nosso estilo
falam muito mais sobre a gente
do que a gente imagina.
E nesse sentido, encontrar o estilo certo
pode ser transformador.
Responder a essas perguntas
sempre foi uma grande motivação pra mim.
Desde a infância, ouvindo o barulhinho
da máquina de costura da minha vó,
vendo aquelas mulheres
nas novelas, "supermontadas",
ou até desenhando as minhas próprias
coleções, com bonecas de papel,
nessa época eu já pensava, já queria,
já tinha esse sonho de trabalhar com moda.
Apesar de não saber muito bem com quê.
E esse sonho só foi crescendo
ao longo do tempo
e, no início da idade adulta,
fez com que eu saísse
da minha cidade natal, Belém,
pra São Paulo, em busca de estudar moda
e conhecer pessoas da indústria,
tentar alguma coisa nessa área.
E muita gente sai de cidades pequenas
pra São Paulo com aquele sonho,
querendo fazer e acontecer
e não demora muito pra ter
um choque de realidade com a cidade.
E comigo, adoraria dizer
que foi diferente, mas não foi.
Cheguei lá pra tentar fazer
o sonho acontecer
e tive uma série de decepções,
tive esse choque de realidade.
E um dos motivos, um dos grandes motivos
é que eu tinha ido estudar moda,
conhecer os grandes eventos
e, na minha cabeça,
era tudo muito idealizado.
Eu achava que era tudo lindo,
maravilhoso, era como as revistas.
E chegando lá, não foi bem assim.
E isso fez com que eu engavetasse
esse sonho por uns anos,
e fosse fazer outras coisas.
Passaram-se vários anos mesmo,
trabalhei em várias áreas diferentes
até que eu recebi uma proposta
para ser apresentadora de TV.
Trabalhei na televisão por seis anos.
E ser apresentadora de TV, eu sei
que é um sonho de muita gente.
Muita gente assiste televisão
e fala: "Nossa, que legal".
Só que não era o meu sonho.
Foi uma coisa que aconteceu.
E diariamente,
podia estar o melhor dos cenários,
mas eu tinha um incômodo assim, aqui.
Alguma coisa não estava resolvida.
Rolava até aquela
síndrome do impostor, sabe?
"Gente, que horas vão descobrir que não
sou apresentadora de TV coisa nenhuma?
Alguém vai chegar aqui e me levar embora,
vai chegar esse momento."
E demorou um tempão pra eu entender
que todo esse sentimento, esse incômodo,
era causado pelo sonho
que eu tinha engavetado anos antes.
E aí, pensando nisso,
depois de muita reflexão,
eu decidi que era hora
de fazer alguma coisa,
e comecei uma série
de transformações pessoais
nesse sentido.
Inclusive transformei meu próprio visual,
meu próprio estilo mudou
e decidi que precisava
voltar a estudar moda.
Comecei a fazer vários cursos
e foi nessa que eu encontrei
a consultoria de estilo.
Encontrei um curso, encontrei a profissão
e finalmente as coisas começaram
a fazer sentido pra mim.
Comecei a entender o que eu queria,
que caminho eu queria seguir na moda
e encontrei a diferença prática
entre moda e estilo, na minha concepção.
É que moda tem muito mais a ver
com um sistema, com um ciclo,
com o fato de que uma coisa precisa cair
pra que outra entre em voga.
E, pra algumas pessoas, "moda"
pode até ser um conceito opressor.
Agora, "estilo" tem muito mais a ver
com autoconhecimento.
Tem muito mais a ver com quem você é
e de que forma expressa isso pro mundo.
E como consultora de estilo,
eu trabalho muito menos
com construção de imagem de moda
e muito mais com construção
de estilo de vida.
As pessoas que eu atendo
são pessoas de verdade,
com sonhos, anseios, dramas pessoais,
felicidades.
São mulheres recém-separadas,
são homens em busca
de desenvolvimento pessoal,
mães que tiveram seus filhos
e esqueceram delas mesmas
e agora estão em busca
dessa personalidade.
Todas essas pessoas são únicas,
um universo em expansão,
mas todas elas têm uma coisa em comum:
elas passam ou passaram, assim como eu,
por uma transformação pessoal
que motivou essa vontade
de mostrar a personalidade delas
por meio do estilo.
Não é fácil, né?
É uma longa jornada pra que isso aconteça.
Uma história que eu gosto de contar
é de uma pessoa que me procurou,
que tinha recém se tratado de um câncer.
Ela tinha perdido muito peso,
tinha passado por um processo
de quimioterapia,
por muita medicação.
E com certeza ela não era mais
a mesma pessoa que tinha sido um dia.
E falando assim vocês devem pensar:
"É uma pessoa, coitada, abatida, triste".
Vocês se enganam porque foi
uma das pessoas mais felizes
que eu tive a oportunidade
de atender na minha profissão.
Ela estava feliz com a vida,
com o simples fato de estar ali,
de estar viva
e querendo reconstruir tudo.
Então nós fizemos vários...
foram muitas conversas,
muita reflexão também.
Fizemos a análise de coloração pessoal,
que é ver que cores ficam melhor
em cada tipo físico.
Fomos observar que roupas
ela tinha no armário.
Aliás, sobre a análise de coloração,
era uma pessoa muito colorida,
ela queria mostrar essa cores pro mundo,
estava com uma avidez disso.
E olhando as roupas dela no guarda-roupa,
a gente teve certeza de que ela
não se enxergava mais ali.
E depois, numa outra parte da consultoria,
que é ir até as lojas e provar roupas
de um estilo que a gente identificou
como sendo o mais próximo ao dela,
uma das grandes alegrias que eu tive,
de pensar que tudo realmente
estava fazendo sentido,
foi de ver o sorriso no rosto dela,
quando se olhou no espelho
e finalmente se reconheceu.
Era isso.
Outra história é de uma jovem executiva
que me procurou
porque tinha sido promovida
pra chefiar uma equipe só de homens
mais velhos do que ela.
E ela, uma mulher
de aparência doce, delicada,
queria passar uma imagem
visual mais incisiva,
se mostrar como líder e principalmente
ser respeitada pela equipe dela.
E fizemos também a consultoria,
conversamos bastante
e depois de todo o processo, ela me deu
um retorno, que me deixou pensando.
Ela me disse que passar a usar
salto alto pra ir ao trabalho,
tinha mudado a vida dela pra melhor.
Porque ela levantava,
ela estava mais alta que aqueles homens
e ela se sentia poderosa.
E isso influenciou várias outras
mudanças na vida dela,
porque fez com que ela
se sentisse mais confiante
em decisões de trabalho,
em várias outras coisas.
E por que isso me deixou pensando?
Porque eu comecei a pensar
que isso que eu falei para vocês agora
de que encontrar o estilo
certo é transformador
porque também mostra quem a gente é,
qual a nossa personalidade,
e é legal, é ótimo.
Mas também tem umas coisas simples,
tipo um corte de cabelo,
um salto alto,
que causam mudanças internas
e fazem com que o nosso interior
coincida com quem a gente quer ser,
com o que a gente busca.
Então é uma via de mão dupla.
Lembram, né? É uma via de mão dupla
porque a gente encontra a felicidade.
Vocês lembram que eu falei
que estava infeliz, tinha um incômodo,
cheguei em São Paulo
e tinha alguma coisa errada.
E eu tive, há uns anos,
a oportunidade de "morder a língua",
me arrepender disso e enxergar a moda
por uma nova perspectiva.
Porque na minha cabeça
tinha uma diferença muito clara,
tinha uma linha, onde
eu não podia ir na moda.
E eu fui convidada por uma marca
que eu admiro muito,
que desfila no São Paulo Fashion Week
pra trabalhar com eles, um tempo atrás,
e, apesar de estar muito feliz
na consultoria de estilo,
eu vi que ali era uma oportunidade
de participar de uma criação de moda
que não era padronizada,
que não estava dentro
daquela coisa que eu delimitei, sabe?
E aceitei, e acabei trabalhando
em três coleções com eles.
Na primeira, eu fiz a parte de "styling",
que é a composição
dos "looks" e dos acessórios,
das fotos de campanha,
cujo principal resultado foi esta foto.
No segundo, eu entrei um pouco mais
no início e fiz a parte de pesquisa
e desenvolvimento da coleção.
Uma coleção chamada "Herança", que tinha
muita inspiração no samba antigo.
Agora, na terceira, eu entrei no início
e fui convidada pra ser
coordenadora de coleção,
que é um trabalho insano,
muita gente vê a superfície
e acha que é fácil, mas eu passei
várias noites sem dormir,
fiquei desesperada, achando
que a coleção não ia sair,
mas todo o esforço valeu a pena
na hora do desfile,
quando surgiu essa imagem na passarela.
Pra quem não conhece, essa é a MC Carol,
é uma cantora de funk do Rio de Janeiro.
É uma pessoa que está completamente fora
dos padrões da indústria da moda
e, consequentemente,
do São Paulo Fashion Week.
É alguém que raramente, talvez nunca
é vista num evento como esse,
é vista numa passarela.
E pra mim, vê-la entrando na passarela
e sendo coroada dessa forma,
depois de todo o trabalho,
foi emocionante,
foi o grande ponto do desfile.
E ela, apesar de ser uma pessoa
que tem fama de que fala o que quer,
e ter letras sobre empoderamento feminino,
é muito tímida
e teve uma preocupação muito grande
com o que ela iria vestir
e como isso seria recebido pelas pessoas.
Talvez por nunca ter se visto
num ambiente como esse.
E foi muito importante,
foi incrível ela entender
a importância de ela estar ali,
pisando nessa passarela, sendo
quem ela é, vinda de onde ela vem
e mostrando pra outras pessoas
que elas podem estar lá também,
que é possível,
servindo como inspiração
pra outras pessoas.
E, principalmente, por ela entender
que a sua autoconfiança,
por estar pisando ali,
é muito mais importante que qualquer look.
E encontrar nosso estilo certo
não é fácil, como eu falei,
é uma transição, requer
muitos questionamentos,
muitas idas e vindas.
E foi por isso que eu perguntei
pra vocês lá no início:
"Por que você usou essa roupa hoje?
Por que você escolheu essa roupa?
O que te levou a escolher?"
Por que tanta gente tem dificuldade
para usar, sei lá, pochete?
Chapéu?
E tem gente que usa isso
com tanta facilidade,
sai de casa e consegue.
E por que tanta gente tem insegurança
em se vestir, no geral?
Justamente em se vestir, uma coisa
que a gente tem que fazer todos os dias.
Se vestir é como comer e beber,
e você vai preso se não se vestir,
se sair pelado.
Então, o meu convite a todo mundo
que tem essas inseguranças
é não olhar tanto pro lado, é pensar
no que aquilo significa pra você.
E como mensagem final,
eu posso deixar três coisas.
A primeira delas é essa, se pergunte
o que é prioridade pra você.
[São] aquelas perguntas lá do começo:
"Eu quero estar confortável?",
"Eu quero estar moderno? Impactante?".
E o que cada uma dessas coisas
significa pra você?
Porque, pra mim,
estar impactante é uma coisa,
talvez pra você seja outra,
completamente diferente.
É pensar nessas respostas com mais cuidado
e que aquelas coisas
de editorial de revista,
de "certo" e "errado", hoje são
completamente inaceitáveis.
Então pensa, a sua prioridade
vale muito mais que qualquer tendência.
Outra coisa é lembrar
que as roupas são um produto
e isso não tem nada a ver
com o seu corpo ser bonito ou ser feio,
não tem nada a ver.
Elas são uma resposta ao mercado,
à oferta e demanda,
a padrões da indústria da moda, à mídia.
Então, por exemplo, se você não achar
uma calça que fique ideal no seu corpo
numa determinada loja,
hoje em dia tem um milhão de opções
pra você procurar por aí.
Dá pra você achar em outros lugares,
só requer um pouco mais de investimento
do seu tempo.
E eu gosto muito de usar
a palavra "investimento",
porque ela vem de "vestimenta".
Porque antigamente a nobreza
tinha umas roupas tão ricas,
que eram bordadas com fios
de ouro e metais preciosos
então, no caso de acontecer alguma coisa,
algum problema financeiro,
as pessoas queimavam as roupas
e caíam fios de ouro
e elas conseguiam se sustentar
por mais um tempo.
Então roupas são sim um investimento.
E então nada mais justo do que investir
o seu tempo no que te faz bem.
E lembrem,
não tem nada a ver com o seu corpo,
o problema não é o seu corpo,
são as roupas.
E lembrar também que,
por mais que você e o seu estilo
estejam completamente desconectados,
você pode pensar: "Estilo?
Eu não tenho estilo, imagina",
todo mundo tem algum estilo.
É só buscar, é uma questão
dessa investigação, que eu falei antes
e pensar que, se existe
uma roupa estranha, esquisita,
que você tem vontade de usar,
por que você não tenta, uma vez?
Qual a pior coisa que pode acontecer,
se você tentar usar?
Vão bater em você na rua? Será?
Talvez você seja julgado,
mas esse julgamento
tem muito mais a ver
com a pessoa que julga
do que com você.
E a melhor coisa que pode acontecer?
É você ter um sorrisão no rosto,
se sentir autêntico,
especial,
único.
E eu convido todo mundo
a se sentir único também,
a se transformar por meio do estilo.
Porque, como já diria Guimarães Rosa,
o que a vida quer da gente
é coragem.
Obrigada.
(Aplausos)